shopify stock sinks 14 after company
says it'll lay off 10 of its work or
cnbc storage shopify is laying off
roughly a thousand workers
which is around 10 global workforce the
company announced tuesday shares of
shopify dropped 14 in a memo
uh to staff ceo toby uh lutky and not
acknowledged he had misguided how long
the pandemic driven e-commerce boom
would last and amanda a broader pullback
in online spending shopify would move
and cut a
number of rolls shop if i had more than
10 000 employees as of december 31st of
2021
shopify bet that the increasing mix of
online spending over commerce in stores
would permanently leap ahead of uh by
five or even ten years luca luther said
it's staffed up to meet what is
anticipated would be a sustained shift
to e-commerce more than doubling its
employee base since 2019 said the
company in february obviously it's in
different situation today by the way you
know who bought 50 million dollars of
shares on the shopify yesterday
50 million who's the lady that was
shorting tesla who's kathy wood she
bought for no no no no she wasn't
shorting tesla she was a fan of tesla i
thought kathy would know you're talking
about arc strategies no no i'm i think
i'm talking about caddy kathy wood about
50 um
uh uh let me pull this up
chunk of coin base after scc probe news
so she's introduced bullish on shopify
she is bullish on shopify but the whole
thing is she's big on
right let's go in here a little bit what
he was saying was very very true there
is an illusion of the shift if you
overread the statistics to e-commerce
because we were locked down so
e-commerce was how we were ordering so
many things and then it's good to be out
again and people going to the grocery
store and things like that not to the
mall but to the grocery store and to
home depot and things like like that so
part of that is a pullback so what he's
saying is i over corrected thinking it
was a permanent correction a permanent
pop we did get growth of e-commerce but
i overreacted say permanent so my next
five moves i have to undo that and i
have to pull back a little bit and oh by
the way the economy is cooling by the
way i think there's a ton that was in
that you know what i'd like to see right
now i haven't looked at it in months i'd
like to see where the stock of zoom is
right now where's zoom stock right now
because that was the hottest stock in
the world tyler 2020 they've already
they've already had their correction it
goes back about six months you gotta
okay let's see that but it's it's a good
question tom break down do a case uh
study on zoom right now take us back six
months here see
go to a year go to a year
you know two years yeah oh wow it's been
going down for a year yeah yeah right
well this is indicative of what the
state of the economy is right now
nobody's relying on zoom anymore 400 to
100. what this is go five years but this
is also pat a ceo in control because it
hasn't
see look at the peak i guarantee it's 20
20. yes
where was it in 2019 do you see the
number well below 200.
huh 80 bucks okay and where was it in
peak in uh 2020 559.
five and where is it now 100. so this is
this is this is a point this is a
telltale sign so in other words you look
at it this way a lot of speculators made
a lot of money in zoom right here but
it's 20
over where it was before pandemic is it
really it did well because in three
verses because now it is a full-on
household name i don't think it was a
household name in 2019. that's what i'm
saying take the spike out yeah the net
value of the company is up 20 percent
over prepended by the way could you do
the exact same thing for the s p 500
if you want to talk about the economy as
a whole no i don't think it's going to
be the same no no way in the world but
take a look go to smp500 we're talking
depression area or the doubt you want to
go to the dao
no pick an index you like no no that's
an easy because
that's an eft etf that's just going to
smp 500. why i didn't know
about that's pretty impressive
tyler man former goldman sachs advisor
to now helping out on the podcast go to
five years
tyler
okay i'm pleased tyler you're going to
come work for me there you go well what
this shows is the economy the and this
is where you got to give some credit to
our friend joe biden
um
2019 where was the s p
below 3 000. yeah right where is it now
and then it went down to 20 to what 2
000. now it's at above four where is it
right now 40 21 okay so according to the
stock market other than that blip in
2020 we're doing better but by the way
zoom's not gonna go away what zoom is
showing that zoom stock i'm glad you
brought that up what that is showing us
is
people are going back to work at the
office that's exactly right that's
what's exactly what that's 20
pandemic so that means so then that's
interesting would it be
i'd be curious to know the correlation
between a market being up versus that
if 20 we have 20 percent more people
working from home now than they did five
years ago i i think that's probably a
right number
24 is a little bit more virtual than
before i think maybe it's like a five or
ten percent hike there's still a lot of
people that are working for home by the
way so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]